>> WHILE THE REST OF AMERICA HAS
MOVED ON FROM THE PANDEMIC, AND
LIFE RETURNS TO NORMAL,
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS ALARMING
PEOPLE WITH TALK OF YET ANOTHER
ONE.
>> WE DO NEED MORE MONEY.
WE JUST DON'T NEED MORE MONEY
FOR VACCINES FOR CHILDREN
EVENTUALLY.
WE NEED MORE MONEY TO PLAN FOR
THE SECOND PANDEMIC.
THERE'S GOING TO BE ANOTHER
PANDEMIC.
WE HAVE TO THINK AHEAD.
>> YEAH.
BUT EARTH TO BIDEN, WE AREN'T
GOING BACK.
EVEN LIBERALS ARE READY TO LET
GO.
"WASHINGTON POST" REPORTEDLY,
THE LATEST COMPANY TO CRACK DOWN
ON STAFF WHO WERE REFUSING A
RETURN TO THE OFFICE.
OKAY.
I REMEMBER, GREG, WHO WAS IT?
I THINK IT WAS FAUCI IN 2016
PREDICTED A PANDEMIC.
NOW BIDEN IS PREDICTING YET
ANOTHER MACADAM.
THEN HE TALKS ABOUT MONEY.
IS THIS ALSO ABOUT PUTTING MONEY
IN BIG PHARMA?
WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
>> I THINK YOU HIT THE NAIL ON
THE HEAD.
HE'S ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT THE
FUTURE, WHICH I GET, BUT IT'S
REALLY ABOUT THE PAST.
LIKE HOW DO YOU PREVENT
SOMETHING FROM HAPPENING?
YOU LOOK AT HOW IT STARTED IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
BRING UP FAUCI.
MAYBE BIDEN SHOULD -- LIKE HE
DOESN'T TELL US HIS ACTUAL
PLANS.
WHY NOT LAUNCH A REAL PRACTICAL
INVESTIGATION INTO THE ORIGINS
OF THE ROOT CAUSES OF COVID.
HOW VITAL WOULD THAT BE AS
OPPOSED TO THIS MONSTROSITY OF A
HEARING THAT WE SEE EVERY DAY
THAT IS JUST POLITICAL THEATRE
BUILT -- IT'S PURE POLITICAL
THEATRE.
IT'S FOR POLITICAL GAIN.
IT'S NOT FOR ANYTHING.
IN THIS CASE IT'S FOR PEOPLE TO
FIND OUT WHY THEIR LOVED ONES
DIE.
NO ONE HAS BEEN ARRESTED.
MILLIONS.
WE'VE DONE NOTHING TO
DISCOVERY -- READ MATT WRIGLEY'S
BOOK, WHICH IS AMAZING ON COVID.
IT WILL BLOW YOUR MIND.
THIS IS JUST LIKE 2019, 2020,
COVID WAS SPREADING, AND WE WERE
DOING IMPEACHMENT THEATRE.
>> YEAH, EXACTLY.
JESSE, WE HAD A ROLE TO PLAY
WITH GAIN OF FUNCTION, FUNDING
IT.
DO YOU THINK THAT HAS SOMETHING
TO DO WITH NOT INVESTIGATING THE
ROOT CAUSES OF COVID?
>> I DO.
FAUCI STILL SUPPORTS GAIN OF
FUNCTION.
FAUCI IS STILL SENDING OUR MONEY
TO SLOPPY CHINESE LABS.
EVEN THE CHINESE CAN'T BELIEVE
THEY'RE SENDING THEM MONEY.
CAN YOU BELIEVE FAUCI IS STILL
SENDING US MONEY?
OKAY, PASS THE BAT.
>> PASS THE BAT?
>> GREG, TO YOUR POINT, WHEN THE
REPUBLICANS TAKE THE HOUSE, I'M
NOT GOING TO SAY RED WAVE, BUT
THEY'LL LAUNCH INVESTIGATIONS
BOO THIS, SUBPOENA FAUCI, HE'LL
PROBABLY BE RETIRED BY THEN, BUT
THEY'LL TRY TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF THIS.
I EXPECT THE PANDEMIC TO RISE UP
PROBABLY BEFORE EACH ELECTION
GOING FORWARD.
I THINK BIDEN IS SAYING THIS
BECAUSE HE'S SO SHELL-SHOCKED
THAT HE MISSED OMICRON AND
ATTEMPT, EVERY TIME HE HEARS
SOMEBODY KNOCK HE THINKS IT'S
ANOTHER VARIANT.
THE DEMOCRATS AREN'T GIVING HIM
MONEY?
FIRST TIME I'VE HEARD THAT.
>> THE AMAZING THING ABOUT
CHINA, ISN'T IT BIDEN TALKING
ABOUT, IF HE HASN'T ALREADY,
TAKING OFF THE TARIFFS OFF
CHINESE GOODS?
>> HE'S CONSIDERING IT.
>> SOME PEOPLE MAKE AN ECONOMIC
ARGUMENT THAT THAT'S CAUSED
INFLATION TO GO UP.
THE TOOL KIT OF POSSIBILITIES,
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS.
>> IT'S A SCHIZOPHRENIC
RESPONSE, THOUGH, DON'T YOU
THINK?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DIDN'T PREPARE FOR CHINESE
TARIFFS TODAY.
>> LET ME HANDLE THIS, DANA.
THAT JOE BIDEN RAN ON GETTING
RID OF COVID, GETTING COVID
UNDER CONTROL.
IT'S TRUE, THERE WILL BE ANOTHER
PANDEMIC, POTENTIALLY IN OUR
LIFETIME.
POSSIBLY NOT.
IF YOU LOOK BACK AT HISTORY.
WHAT DID WE DO THAT WORKED AND
DIDN'T WORK?
THE LOCKDOWNS DIDN'T WORK.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS TO PUT
INTO THE CODE BOOK, WHEN YOU
HAVE A NEW PANDEMIC, LOOK UP IN
50 YEARS, WHAT HAPPENED?
THEY SHUT DOWN THE ECONOMY, THAT
DID NOT WORK, KIDS DID NOT
LEARN, AND THAT'S AN EFFECTIVE
USE OF GOVERNMENT FUNDS NOW TO
PUT IT TOGETHER.
SOLVE THE LIKE AFTER KATRINA,
FEMA IS MUCH MORE PREPARED TO
DEAL WITH NATURAL DISASTERS.
>> FINAL WORD?
>> WARP SPEED, WHAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP DID, APPEARS TO HAVE
WORKED FROM THE STANDPOINT THAT
THESE VACCINES WERE SAFE.
WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT THAT AS A
PLATFORM GOING FORWARD.
I THINK EVERY GREAT LEADER,
WHETHER YOU'RE A COACH, A CEO,
WHETHER YOU'RE A POLITICIAN, OR
YOU'RE A PRODUCER, HEAD OF A
NETWORK, THINK ABOUT WHAT WORKS
AND WHAT DOESN'T WORK, THEN YOU
TRY TO PREPARE FOR CHALLENGES
GOING FORWARD.
YOU HAVE TO INNOVATE ALWAYS.
SO THINGS WE DIDN'T HAVE,
VACCINES, THERAPEUTICS, SEMI
CONDUCTOR CHIPS, POTATO CHIPS,
TOILET PAPER.
THEY SHOULD NEVER FACE THAT KIND